[Music]  too often cancer cuts life short and  shatters families especially when cancer  hits children it can affect them for the  rest of their lives almost 4 million  Europeans per year are diagnosed with  cancer this disease still kills 1.2  million people per year but there is  good news  screening diagnosis treatment and  survival rates are improving all the  time but we still need to do more  together together we have to improve  prevention together we have to care  football together we can save lives with  more and better research and innovation  the European Commission has set up a  board of top scientists clinicians and  patient representatives to advise on how  best to do this because we all have  experience of cancer either directly or  through loved ones friends and  colleagues and because we are in Europe  let's work on this mission to fight  cancer together  tell us your concerns what needs to  improve let's share this journey  together  [Music]  you